The ocean conveyor belt
and the Gulf stream.
Ocean currents have a direct
influence on our lives.
They determine now whether our climate
and much more the ocean currents and wind
systems transport heat from the equator
to the polls and operate like a large
engine for the global climate.
In the oceans there are numerous currents.
The so called ocean conveyor belt
is very important for our climate.
This term describes a combination of
currents that result in four of the five
global oceans exchanging
water with each other.
They form a worldwide segregation system.
The conveyor belt is also called the
thermal halon circulation with thermo
referring to the temperature and he
to the salt content of the water.
Both determine the density of the water
while the masses of water maybe moved in
part by wind.
Primarily the different densities of the
global oceans are responsible for their
movement.
Warm water has a lower density and rises.
Whoa.
Cold waters sinks.
The water's density also increases with
the higher salt content at the equator.
The heat from the sun
is especially strong,
resulting in a lot of evaporation and
that's a rise in the water. Salt content.
That is where the Gulf stream begins.
The Gulf Stream is very important
for the European climate.
It's length of 10,000 kilometers,
makes it one of the largest and fastest
ocean currents on earth and it's very
warm at roughly two meters a second.
It brings up to 100 million cubic meters
of water burst second towards Europe,
eight constantly blowing wind.
The southeast Tradewinds drives
warm surface water to the northwest,
into the Gulf of Mexico where it
heats up to 30 degrees Celsius.
The turning of the earth and the West
winds then direct the Gulf stream towards
Europe and split it up.
One part flow south,
another east to the canary current
and a third part flows north where it
releases a lot of heat into the
atmosphere. As the North Atlantic current,
the water becomes colder there.
It's salt content and identity density
rise on account of evaporation and it
drops down between Greenland,
Norway, and Iceland. There.
We also find the largest waterfall
on earth, the so called chimneys,
roughly 15 kilometer wide pillars
with water falling up to 4,000 meters,
17 million cubic meters of water per
second or roughly 15 times more water than
is carried by all the rivers in the world.
This creates a strong male strong,
which constantly pulls in new water and
is the reason that the Gulf stream moves
towards Europe.
Countless species use the Gulf stream
as a means of transport on their trips
from the Caribbean to northern areas,
but it doesn't just bring us animals and
enormous quantity of warmer also comes
with us.
In order to reduce the same heat which
it brings to the shores of Europe,
we would need 1 million
nuclear power plants.
That's why we also call the Gulf
stream a heat pump. Without it,
the temperature would be significantly
colder here at these five to 10 degrees.
Instead of lush fields,
we would have long winters and spouse
ice covered landscapes in Europe.
In the last few years,
scientists and pundits in the media have
repeatedly express the fear that the
Gulf stream could come to a standstill
due to climate change because if the
polar caps actually melt,
the salt content in the water off
Greenland would fall as what its density.
The North Atlantic current would no
longer be heavy enough and so it wouldn't
sync as usual
in the worst case,
that would bring the Gulf
stream our heat pump to a stop.
Some climates experts also assume that
climate change could compensate for this
effect.
We know that it can be normal for the
climate to change by looking at the
development of the earth over
the last few million years,
there are ice ages and warm periods.
In the last ice age,
a gigantic flood of melting
water tripled the heat.
Bringing North Atlantic current
covering the northern hemisphere in ice.
Scientists have different views on the
impact that climate change will have on
the global ocean conveyor belt.
But one thing is clear
when the climate changes,
then the complex system of
ocean currents and winds,
which has remained fairly
stable since the last ice age,
will change in ways that
we don't yet understand.
Okay.